[MUSIC PLAYING]
MATTHEW HENDERSHOT: Please put
your hands together, welcome
to the stage Mr. Wyclef Jean.
[APPLAUSE]
WYCLEF JEAN: Y'all good?
AUDIENCE: Yes.
WYCLEF JEAN: Sorry
for the shades.
I'm a little smoked out.
[LAUGHTER]
Cool one, two.
Yeah.
So could you turn
the mic up a little?
Just for me, thanks.
Yeah.
So it's an honor to be
here with y'all at Google.
And I was sitting over there.
I was like, "man, I was such
a bad student in school.
I don't know how this happened."
So I was coming here, and
I had my two guitar cases,
and dude's like,
"yo, this is Wyclef,
where are your bodyguards?
You know what I mean?
And I'm like, "dude,
I'm from Brooklyn.
What can a bodyguard do for me?
I needed the bodyguard when
I was in the projects."
You know what I'm saying?
I'm good now.
But I move like this
because in my mindset,
where I come from
being born in Haiti
and having the chance
to come to America,
getting that chance to
experiment the American Dream,
the reality of being famous
till today has not struck me.
You know what I mean?
But two things have
made me realize
that I'm kind of famous.
So the first thing that made
me realize I'm kind of famous
was when Young Thug was
tracking Lyor Cohen down.
Like, "yo, you gotta
find me Wyclef Jean.
I need Wyclef Jean now!"
And I'm like, "why is
Thugga looking for me?"
Man.
Just you know?
And then I get with
Thugga, and he's
like, "yo, you know you're one
of my greatest inspirations.
You know my tattoo says Haiti,
my daughter named Haiti.
I wish I was from Haiti, man!"
So I was like "OK, cool."
So and then he named
the song "Wyclef Jean."
And the second thing
that occurred to me
was a couple of weeks ago I
get stopped by the police.
I get cuffed.
And as I'm being
cuffed, I'm like "yo,
my name is Wyclef Jean."
"Yeah.
Yeah, your name is
really Wyclef Jean.
Yeah, that's really
Wyclef Jean."
And I realized that
my name is actually
more famous than the person.
So now I have to accept
that I'm kind of famous.
So on that note, what I'm going
to do is I'm going to take
y'all on a trip.
I call it "From Cassettes."
And the very last song
that I'll end up doing
is probably a song that's
streaming, I think,
over 40 million.
It's called "Hendrix."
So we'll start from
the Cassette Era.
I'll just take y'all
through a flashback,
and then somehow I ended
up in the Streaming Era,
which is cool.
[MUSIC - WYCLEF JEAN, "READY OR
NOT"]
They call me Wyclef because
I flip the language.
I called Donald Trump and
freestyled in Spanish, like--
[SINGING IN SPANISH]
Yeah, Pence wasn't convinced,
but they got convinced when
I flipped it in French, like--
[SINGING IN FRENCH]
[SINGING IN ENGLISH AND GERMAN]
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC - WYCLEF JEAN - "GONE
TILL NOVEMBER"]
[APPLAUSE]
Thank you, thank you.
So Drake calls me Uncle
Clef when he picks me up.
I'm getting kind of old, man.
So that was a little
"Gone Till November."
My music is like--
I'm inspired by Bob
Dylan and Bob Marley.
So in the hood, they
call me a thug hippie.
Just give peace a chance,
trying to figure it out.
So we'll move to another
era, which is cool.
This is called "Someone
Please Call 911."
Sound man, what
you smoking, dog?
[MUSIC - WYCLEF JEAN,
"SOMEONE PLEASE CALL 911"]
[APPLAUSE]
So what y'all probably
realizing is like, "holy shit,
this kid is actually an
amazing singer as well.
We didn't know he'd be
doing all them high notes
and shit for real.
We thought he'd adjust it in
the studio with auto-tune."
Now, I was raised in my
daddy's church, so what I love,
I was a choir director.
So I just loved producing music.
So a lot of the stuff that I've
written for different people,
whether if it was Santana, or
Destiny's Child, Shakira, most
of the stuff, I demo it myself.
So y'all don't get a chance
to actually hear the demos,
so this is actually cool because
y'all get to hear the cut, raw,
like before it
actually goes out.
You know what I mean?
So like when I was in
the studio with Santana
but before Santana?
So Santana got this.
He got this demo.
It was like-- let's see.
It was like--
[MUSIC - WYCLEF JEAN, "MARIA,
MARIA"]
And I know y'all ain't know what
the hell we were saying on that
"ola binga."
And I don't credit myself
for the "ola binga,"
but growing up, I
used to like listening
to a lot of Lionel Richie.
And there's some shit
he'd do in, I think,
it's like "All Night
Long," where's it's like,
[SINGING GIBBERISH]
And I was like, "man."
I tell you, if Lionel
Richie could get away
with that, that's the man.
All I gotta do is just make up
some "ola binga" and people--
and it ended up rocking.
So I'll do one more tune.
This is the one
that's streaming.
For the kids, this
has reinvented me
to a new generation.
They think Wyclef
is a new rapper
that Young Thug is putting out.
So.
[LAUGHTER]
This is from the EPA
called "J'ouvert."
If you haven't got a chance
to check it out, please do.
Got a lot of vibes on it.
Just going to do this
last acrobatics for y'all.
This is my acoustic track.
You know what I mean?
[MUSIC - WYCLEF JEAN, "HENDRIX"]
[APPLAUSE]
MATTHEW HENDERSHOT:
Please, one more time.
One more time.
Keep it going for Wyclef Jean.
[APPLAUSE]
Thanks for playing,
thanks for playing.
So also joining us
on stage right now
is Madeleine Nelson, who
is with Heads Music, which
is Wyclef's label and
management company right now.
MADELINE NELSON: Yeah.
MATTHEW HENDERSHOT: So
please welcome Madeline.
MADELINE NELSON: Hi, everybody.
[APPLAUSE]
MATTHEW HENDERSHOT: So
excellent performance.
Thank you for coming
to be here today.
It's a great New York
day, and made even better
by a wonderful performance.
We're happy to have you.
WYCLEF JEAN: Thank you, man.
MATTHEW HENDERSHOT: The
reason, or multiple reasons,
why you're here--
I'm sure we can
make a laundry list,
but it goes back to the recent
release of "J'ouvert," which
was an EP signaling the
beginning of Carnival
and leading us to what will be
this summer's "The Carnival 3."
On the 20th anniversary
of "The Carnival,"
you're now releasing
"The Carnival 3."
What is the appeal to
being a sequel album?
Why are we still
living in the carnival?
WYCLEF JEAN: Well, the era
that we're in right now,
we're in the era of the Drakies,
the eras of the Rihannas,
the eras of the afrobeat
movement, which is spawning.
In 1997, when I was coming
out with The Carnival," which
is an album with a lot of these
like futuristic world beat
rhythms against hip
hop rhythms, this
is why it allows this new one
to be part of that sequel.
So a kid who'd never
heard "The Carnival," one
like my daughter, she's
bumping "J'ouvert."
So while she's bumping
"J'ouvert," she's like,
"dad, do a song with Drake."
So Drake is like her Wyclef.
You see what I'm saying?
Now, but when Drake is like,
"yo, your dad is really cool.
I listen to "The Carnival."
So now she hasn't heard "The
Carnival," so "The Carnival
3" will be her first experience
with that explosion of what
happened in '97 mixed with 2017.
And it's themed like that,
because it has a world
rhythm to it along with the
hip hop and everything else.
MATTHEW HENDERSHOT: You
mentioned the word "theme,"
and that's always been
a big deal for me.
Because I think back to
the original "Carnival"
and even "The Score"
before that, and these
are not just
collections of songs.
This is an album that
you sit, you listen to,
you get told a wonderful story.
How important is this sort
of storytelling thing to you
in the creation process?
It's not just like,
"hey, here's a good hook.
Build around it." it's like,
you've got a story to tell.
WYCLEF JEAN: Yeah, it's
tricky because you've
got two generations.
So my daughter, she's
just skip, skip, forward.
She's like, "OK,
what's the next single?
What's the next single?"
But then she will sit there
and listen to Adele's album.
Because at the end of the
day, it's a body of work.
So you're dealing
with two audiences.
You've got "The Carnival"
cult classic audience, which
is "The Score."
If they hear
"Carnival 3," they're
not planning to go and put
on a CD and skip and skip.
They know what the classic is.
So they're going to see
if song one can go to two,
can go to three, can go to four.
My daughter's generation
is a little different.
So the way that we're going
to approach this is two sides.
They'll be the audio
and the visual.
So it's more of a
visual generation.
So what I want to do this
time, unlike on "Carnival 1,"
when I used the skits
to take you there,
because we weren't that advanced
with Google and everything yet.
So I created my own Google.
I was like, "ah, let me
do this audio Google."
So now in the era
that we're in, we're
basically-- what I'm going to
do is take the entire album,
and it's going to be what I
call a hip hop urban opera,
where all of the
visuals now will
be shot where the
visuals go thematically
with the next songs.
And similar to
"Carnival 1," now you'll
be able to discover new
artists that you don't know.
So the cool thing is with
"Carnival 1," who's John Forte?
Who is?
Now with "Carnival 3," a lot
of the talents, like being
able to come up, working with
Lauryn Hill, Beyonce, Shakira,
Mary J, Little Wayne,
and not Little Wayne.
Now I'm talking about Jah Rule,
50 Cent, all of this back then.
I'm just saying, this
is how it started.
I watched the evolution
of a lot of these kids.
With "The Carnival
3," you will start
to see a lot of
evolution of what
we feel is the future of
where talent is going.
So that's what's going
to make this exciting.
MATTHEW HENDERSHOT: Cool.
So we're looking forward
to a lot of new talent.
Still staying on the
subject a little bit,
and Madeleine, maybe
this is something
that you can speak to, in this
idea of not just putting out
an album, with
"Carnival," you originally
could get it on
vinyl or cassette,
like we were talking about.
CD was the least seller
for that to come out.
Now in the world, we're not even
really buying physical media
any more.
MADELINE NELSON: Right.
MATTHEW HENDERSHOT: How
important from an artist
perspective and also
from a label perspective
is the diversification
of where you're
making yourself available?
You talked a lot about
streaming services,
the sort of visual movie audio
thing for YouTube and online.
How is this calculus done?
MADELINE NELSON: So
it's super important.
When Wyclef made "The Carnival"
album 20 years ago-- in June,
it's going to be 20 years--
people were buying that
album on cassette tapes,
on CDs, and on vinyl.
The least amount of people
were buying on CD, though.
And then we did the
"The Carnival 2,"
which is then 10 years ago.
So he's got these 10 year
gaps of these "Carnival"
albums, which I think is
also important to note.
10 years ago it was all CD.
But there was
still no streaming.
I think none of the
services even existed
when "The Carnival 2" happened.
And then there
was a serious gap,
because there was
tons of music that
was being made on Wyclef and
on other artists like Carlos
Santana, and Whitney
Houston, and Shakira,
all in between one and two.
But between "Carnival 2"
and now "Carnival 3," Wyclef
wasn't putting
music on the market.
So not only did
"Carnival 2" happen right
before streaming happened, then
there was just no from Wyclef
in the 10 year gap.
So we hit 8, 9, 10
years later, and we're
starting to put music out
again, and essentially there's
only streaming.
It is where the young
folks we're talking about
are running out to
physically purchase an album.
So we really had
to sort how do you
take an artist who last released
music before streaming even
existed and make them relevant
on all those streaming
platforms?
The good fortune is
the artist is Wyclef,
and his music is amazing,
no matter how long
it takes him to start putting
music back on the market again.
But it's been interesting
for us as a label,
being a really, really young
indie label, never really
having dealt with physical, only
understanding digital, to work
with an artist like Wyclef,
who was all physical releases,
and now we had to figure our
way in this digital world.
And what has happened is,
he's done something amazing.
Because it is a huge, huge
20 year gap, and "Hendrix,"
like he spoke about, had a point
on Spotify on each playlist
that they would put it, all
the way up to Rap Caviar.
If anybody knows, that the
creme de la creme on Spotify.
But it was the least skipped
song on each playlist,
from a guy who hadn't put
music on streaming ever
before that song
went to streaming.
So it's really, really
interesting to watch the path,
watch the journey, and to see
him do something really rare,
to be able to start
at cassette tape
and-- we call it "cassette
tape to streaming rates,"
is what we've been calling
the whole marketing
piece from "Carnival
1 20th Anniversary"
to putting out "The Carnival 3."
MATTHEW HENDERSHOT: And what
do you think, as the artist
coming into this landscape?
It's not as simple anymore
as just cutting it to tape
and being done.
There's a lot more work
involved now, it seems.
WYCLEF JEAN: Yeah, but I really
don't look at life like that.
You feel me?
I'm just a different breed.
I don't believe
music is supposed
to be put out
because it's supposed
to go to a commercial
space, or you're
supposed to plan in your
brain "do these analytics."
I believe your life, you
should be doing a lot with it.
So at times, music
is just the gift.
And then I think public
service and different things
that we do, all of
these things are what
actually inspires the music.
People inspire people.
So I think what happens
is, it's like the death
of a lot of artists when their
whole existence in living
is to put out music
to please a public.
I mean, that's the
most dangerous thing,
because you'll get
caught up in a gap.
so it's like if we didn't
do "The Score," if we didn't
do "The Carnival," I
remember like "The Carnival,"
these albums, the companies
thought I was crazy
when I was putting it out.
But I was like, "yo, I
want to be like Basquiat."
When you put art out, art
will live long after you,
and we will discover it.
So I just feel like,
"OK, we're in the era
we have the YouTube."
So the YouTube for me is the new
record crates for my daughter.
She sees a name.
That's where she goes back
and gets all this information.
So I think that the space
that you take in between,
it's just important that, OK,
even if I ain't putting music
out, y'all still see
me doing other things.
Because sometimes-- I call
it my John Lennon moment.
Sometimes, there are things that
are more important than music.
Then, when you
decide that you're
going to put the music out and
you're going to make it right,
the first thing is, you have
to find an executive that you
can really trust.
So in no way am I calling myself
a genius, but at 17 years old,
I was a jazz prodigy.
I played like 12
different instruments,
self-taught, all of that.
So who the hell am I
going to listen to?
So you know what I'm saying?
So I'll tell you who
I'm listening to at 17.
I mean, I was listening to--
I did an off
Broadway musical play
called "Club 12," and
I saw Quincy Jones.
And I was amazed by
Q, and I was like, "Q,
I'm going to be
like you when I--"
He's like, "keep
going, young man."
And then years later,
I see Q at the Grammys.
And then having a chance
to work with Clive Davis,
spending time with Clive
Davis, spending time
with Jimmy Iovine, Tommy
Mottola, Donnie Ienner,
crafting through music.
I was like, "OK,
in this millennium,
I'm in a new millennium
and I want to do music.
Who am I going to
do music with?"
Because the trust
factor is so important.
And I bumped into a
small indie, where
it was completely run by women.
You know what I mean?
I love men, but women,
when they do things, man,
they put that extra thing to it.
So I got with this indie,
and all of a sudden,
we had the real conversations.
And so my job is to
constantly make music.
And I think someone
else's job has
to be to carve out how
they bring the music
to the next generation.
That's not the part I'm good at.
So I think that
when it works best
is when the artist and
the executive brain
gels as one brain.
I think that's when
you get the magic,
and I think that's what we're
getting out of everything
we're putting out now.
MATTHEW HENDERSHOT:
That's great.
I did want to touch on
a little bit of that.
You talked about your
early on influences
and being inspired by greats
like Quincy Jones and this.
Coming back to do
a new record, I've
been listening to
some of the stuff,
and for a song like "Hendrix,"
you go and listen to that,
and there's some very new,
very modern sonic stuff.
A piece that leaps to mind
is the "El Chapo" portion
being a little on thee
designer-esque repetition
vibe in the sonic evolution.
Was that a conscious decision
to look around at the landscape
and say like, "OK, this is
how I can bridge that gap?"
Because it's still very island
and world music as well.
Or was that just the
nature of-- these
are the influences
that are around you,
sort of passive influence?
WYCLEF JEAN: Great question.
So the answer to that is, blues
gets translated into what?
It starts off as blues.
We go into jazz.
We go into bebop.
What we do is we
adjust the cadence.
So designer is a cadence.
[SPEAKING GIBBERISH]
That's a cadence.
But-- [SCATTING]
So as someone who creates
music, every time has a cadence.
And the cadence is the
way of communication.
So the '90s cadence
was like this.
Woodpecker.
That was just the cadence.
And people were like,
"yo, Wy, it's going
to break your neck like this."
And so the beat
was going this way.
So now my daughter, their
cadence is like this.
So it's very
important, because what
I'm doing is-- so
mathematically,
I'm adjusting to a cadence.
Because the cadence
is what determines
if you get the pulse or
you don't get the pulse.
So even like in Jay-Z
in the "Tom Ford" song,
you'll see he'll take
four bars and go [HUMMING]
and then he'll go back
to Jay-Z. OK, I get it.
The problem is now, if you
don't understand the cadence.
So if we go from blues
to bebop to jazz to R&B,
there's still cadences that
we have to incorporate.
So it's important
to understand that.
Now, the bad part about it
is, if you don't understand
that, you heard Clef and I was
like [SINGING GIBBERISH] you'd
be like, "what the fuck
happened to Wyclef?"
MADELINE NELSON: And
that happened too.
I was getting calls from
people like, "oh, Wyclef's
doing trap music now?
And so instead of getting
defensive, I said, "no,
he's doing acoustic
trap music now."
Those same people were calling
about the streaming numbers
of "Hendrix."
MATTHEW HENDERSHOT: Yeah.
Well, it does
accomplish the goal
of bringing a very
unique style of music.
WYCLEF JEAN: Well,
communication is key.
MADELINE NELSON: Yeah.
WYCLEF JEAN: Like,
if you're going
to do music for
my daughter, it's
up to who you want
to do music for.
So I say, "OK, I want to reach
out to now a new generation."
So if you're doing that,
you have to know the lingo.
You have to know the language.
You have to know
every form of work,
or you could just be like, "OK."
And I learned this being in
a studio with Michael Jackson
and understanding the pulse
is always with the child.
Once you lose that
pulse of the child--
I don't care if it's
technology, music, movies.
We could go back to books 2,000
years ago that we will read,
our kids will read.
Why?
Because it's written
from that innocence.
So whenever it's
time to do that,
you have to at least
understand all of the cadence
that we're dealing with.
MATTHEW HENDERSHOT: Yeah, like
a foreigner in a foreign land.
At least "hello," "thank
you," and maybe "how
to order a beer."
WYCLEF JEAN: Yeah, and you
gotta know how to trip.
And you know what's funny
is, when I'm going like--
[SPEED RAPPING]
And then my daughter is
like, "dad, I love that flow.
That sounds like the Migos."
[LAUGHTER]
And it's funny, though.
You see?
The cadence sounds
like the Migos to her,
but that's speed rapping
that we did in the late '80s.
But you see what I'm saying?
But to her, Migos
introduced it to her.
Then I have to show
her Migos saying
"I'll be gone till November
on that Wyclef kush."
And she says, "oh, OK, dad.
I see."
But it's cool, though.
It shows you.
But think about it.
So I'm doing a flow like,
duh-duh-uh, speed rapping.
And now this same
flow comes back.
Once again, it's that
cadence and being
able to adjust to the cadence.
Always remember, the song--
the song is the song.
If you write an incredible
song, it's the song.
Now, to adjust, all you
do is adjust to song
is you adjust the
sonics of the time.
The sun will always be the sun.
The moon will
always be the moon.
But we humans, the sun was
out in the Egyptian times,
but they didn't have Google.
Or maybe they did?
In a different form.
I don't know.
But we did was we adjust.
As humans, we adjust.
So the songs, the
moons, that's the sun.
And we as humans, we
adjust to the cadence.
But we don't sacrifice
the sun for nothing.
You know?
MATTHEW HENDERSHOT: Yeah,
it's always back like before.
Very good.
[APPLAUSE]
So there was a
mention of this 10
years of no music from Wyclef.
But that's not because you were
just hiding out and relaxing.
You were actually quite
busy during that time.
WYCLEF JEAN: And I
was putting out music.
It was just music that
wasn't in a commercial space.
MADELINE NELSON: Yeah.
MATTHEW HENDERSHOT: Right, OK.
WYCLEF JEAN: Right?
MATTHEW HENDERSHOT: Of course.
WYCLEF JEAN: You look at
every artist through history.
Even Stevie Wonder
taught me that.
We have what's called the
light days and the dark days.
And the dark days are not
that we have writer's block.
It just means that we tapped
out of a certain space.
Because you can start and be
like, "yo, I want to be on TV!
I want to be--"
then, as you're going
and you're constantly
on TV, you're
constantly on the
radio, you're constantly
breaking chart records,
that could get boring, dude.
Believe it or not.
Because you're like, "yo,
what am I going to do next?"
When dudes go, "yo,
all right, Wyclef Jean
just topped Michael Jackson
and Elvis Presley best radio
airplay song of all time,"
[INAUDIBLE],, you go,
"OK, man, it's just
failure for me."
MATTHEW HENDERSHOT:
Nowhere to go but down.
WYCLEF JEAN: It
was sort of like--
so I tapped out of music,
but if you look back ever
since the Fugee, whether it
was the Tibetan Freedom concert
or Rock the Vote,
different things,
we were more on the active side.
So it wasn't even
trying to be famous.
So think about it.
"Fugees" is short
for "refugees."
You could go back
in '96, '95, '94.
Look at my interviews,
listen to what I'm saying.
I'm saying we chose this
name because, coming
from an immigrant background,
having family that
have died on the shores of Cuba,
trying to make it to Miami,
running from dictators, we
choose this name because we're
going to take what they
look at as a negative
and we're going
to make it so fly.
So for me, this is my DNA.
So 20 years later, when
I step out, I was like,
"I don't want to be that guy
when 250,000 of my people
are under the rubble, and all
of the youth in my country
look up to me, and it's
like, oh, what did he do?
Oh, he sang some more
songs and he danced."
No, I believe in public service.
So I sacrificed my entire
career, everything.
Politics is dirty, man.
I mean, Trump knows now.
Politics is like, they'll
take anything and make it--
because it's almost like you're
entering a different realm.
You have to understand,
once you're into politics,
you're basically saying,
"I have submitted myself
to my constituents."
Basically, your city, your town.
And so I basically submitted
myself to my country of Haiti.
That came first in those
10 years before the music.
So that's why the music
was like Dark Age,
because it was more like,
"how can I help my people?"
And all the way trying to become
the president of my country,
I mean, dude.
I mean, this is no joke.
Like everything
you're reading about,
I mean, this little dude who's
sitting here, I'm no joke, man.
I could hear my
friends like-- you know
I mean-- in the background.
"Yeah, you know I'm going to--"
I've got my Luther King voice.
"I'm going to become
the president of Haiti."
And I could hear my boys in
that back, "that nigga crazy!"
You know what I'm saying?
But for me, it was
important that you step up
to the occasion.
And this is what Martin
Luther King teaches us.
Having spent one on one
time with Nelson Mandela,
like one on one, and
getting to pick his brain.
"Yo, Nelson, man, they had
you up, and you get out,
and you find forgiveness.
You set up these
courts, and say, well,
the oppressor could come
talk to the accuser."
What is this about?
So in understanding this, it
always goes back to humanity.
And our real weapon is love.
So it was incredible to take
those 10 years out and figure
that out and be able to
come back in this space,
because I have so
much more to give now.
Because it feels
like a new start.
MATTHEW HENDERSHOT: Well, and
it seems, as a fan of the music,
that one of the common
themes is the carnival,
the subcommon theme has always
been politics, sociopolitics.
WYCLEF JEAN: Yes.
MADELINE NELSON: Yeah.
MATTHEW HENDERSHOT: And
speaking to those things,
and actually seeing
an artist who--
P-Diddy can say, "oh,
go rock the vote,"
and then he doesn't
even show up to vote.
But you put yourself out there.
WYCLEF JEAN: P-Diddy my man, yo.
[LAUGHTER]
MATTHEW HENDERSHOT:
I'm not trying
to take a shot at him, but--
WYCLEF JEAN: Yo,
dude, listen, man.
Don't do that to P. Because,
dude, don't do that.
I need my Ciroc delivered
at the next show, brah.
Please, I don't want Diddy
to be like, "yo, Clef,
I saw you on Google
with your man.
What's up with him, man?"
And I'm like, "P, let
me get that peach."
"Nah, man.
You're have to hold
up on that, Cleffy."
MATTHEW HENDERSHOT: All right.
Very fair, very fair, very fair.
We do want to open
it up to audience
questions for the last
few minutes we have here.
So if you have questions, please
make your way to the mics.
But one last thing before we go.
So "The Carnival
3" does come out.
And it is the 20th
anniversary of "The Carnival."
WYCLEF JEAN: Yeah.
MATTHEW HENDERSHOT: "The
Score" was released in 2000--
1996.
Does that mean 2021 we get
25th anniversary Fugees
"Settle the Score?"
WYCLEF JEAN: I don't know.
That sounds great.
I think you just hit--
I think you just pitched
in and Lauryn and Pras just
saw this right now.
Yeah, it sounds great.
And "Carnival 3," what's
the preorder date?
The date it comes out?
MADELINE NELSON: So you will be
able to preorder on June 23rd.
So that is the 20th
anniversary of "The Carnival."
So while we're celebrating
the 20th anniversary
of "The Carnival," you
can preorder "Carnival 3,"
and there's probably going to
be two amazing instant grat
songs for the preorder.
And then later this summer,
the album will be released.
And we're not going to
talk about the date.
There's just going to be
a day when you can get it.
And you're going to
love the instant grat
so much that you're definitely
going to get the album?
MATTHEW HENDERSHOT: When can
I get my limited edition 12
inch custom side vinyl?
WYCLEF JEAN: You got it, man.
We got you.
MADELINE NELSON: Oh, of course!
WYCLEF JEAN: Definitely.
MATTHEW HENDERSHOT: All
right, perfect, perfect.
Let's take some questions
from the audience.
Please.
AUDIENCE: Hey, Wyclef.
WYCLEF JEAN: Sir.
AUDIENCE: Thank
you for being here.
WYCLEF JEAN: Thank you, baby.
AUDIENCE: And for
sharing with us
these great songs and
information about the Egyptian
Google and light and dark days.
But thank you especially
for starting us off
with a couple of songs from
"The Score" and "Gone Till
November," and making
us older Googlers not
feel quite so irrelevant.
But as somebody who grew
up in New York in the '80s,
I have a more
important question,
which is those were the
days of Doc and Darryl.
How can you be
wearing a Yankees hat?
MATTHEW HENDERSHOT: He's
questioning your Yankees hat.
AUDIENCE: Are you
really a Yankees fan?
I respect the Yankees, but--
WYCLEF JEAN: Oh,
that's a good question.
No, that's a good question.
I came out here today,
and I'm supporting
this Yankees hat because
of my daughter right now.
So basically she's seen
a hat like this on Jay-Z.
And this is a true story.
And she was like, "dad, you
should rock a fitted like Jay."
So purely, there is no baseball
analogy today at all for me.
But if we were to have
a baseball analogy, when
I used to collect
the cards, I used
to collect Reggie Jacksons
and Willie Randolphs.
Those were my favorites
coming up in the '80s
that I used to collect.
AUDIENCE: They
were pretty great.
WYCLEF JEAN: Yeah,
those were my homies.
I mean, I didn't
know them personally,
but those were the cards.
AUDIENCE: Me neither.
WYCLEF JEAN: Exactly.
MATTHEW HENDERSHOT: Please.
AUDIENCE: Hi, you mentioned
about giving back to Haiti.
And I mean, Haiti still
has many problems,
the widespread poverty, and
infrastructure, and everything.
And last time, you tried
to give back to them
through Yele Haiti.
You got a lot of
criticism in the press
about it misappropriation of
funds and, like, for example,
hundreds of thousands
dollars in contracts
to your brother-in-law that
didn't actually materialize
and $100,000 to you
for a benefit concert.
And I was wondering if that
experience, which was obviously
a really hard thing
to do, dissuaded you
from having a future
impact there, as well
as a presidential
run as well, if you
are going to have similar
large-scale endeavors to help
Haiti, and if so, what you
would do differently then?
WYCLEF JEAN: Well,
the first part
to the tear of your question
is, I denounce everything
that the New York Times said.
And I had an article
where I posted up
the response of denouncing
the fact that I used charity
funds to benefit myself, the
idea of taking contracts,
to lower that to my family.
The bigger picture of that is,
at the time, if you go back
and you look now, you'll see
that the billion dollars went
to Red Cross, and you can
see the amount of houses
they built. You could look into
different foundations and see.
In the process, I felt that
Yele Haiti was a patsy.
It was a distraction
for a bigger
picture that was going on, and
I was the face of a celebrity.
And actually, in my country, it
actually made me more powerful.
Because in order
for you to break me,
you've got to turn
my people against me.
So past that, if you noticed,
I took it a step further
and ran to become
president of my country.
And past that, right
now I'm working
with the current government.
And my plan is
basically to be part
of a watchdog for NGOs
coming into my country that
have tried to set me up,
and to make sure that--
Because whether you're
talking about Haiti
or you're talking about
Africa or different places,
these places are basically--
long before we were born,
they were created by designs to
be a back door, where one man's
tragedy is another man's gain.
I'm not saying that there
is not people that's
doing good work on the ground.
So through my experience,
what I've learned
is, the best impact for my
country will not be charity.
It will be social
entrepreneurship.
I feel like charity
and aid is a Band-Aid.
To get past the [INAUDIBLE],,
to get past that,
we have to work closer
with private sector,
with government, and
to get them to come up
with more job structures.
And this is not
just a Haiti thing.
It's an American thing.
It's in Afghanistan thing.
It's a Pakistan thing.
It's the idea of saying,
if you want to things
to change in the
rural communities,
we, as investors, have to
invest in these countries.
You've got different
telecom companies
that are coming into
these countries that
are making billions of dollars.
And their whole philosophy
is, "they're poor,
but they're going to buy
a pack of cigarettes."
You know what I mean?
And then so the idea, if they
can buy a pack of cigarettes,
why can't you give them a job?
So through my experience,
we plan to be more powerful.
We're working with the
current administration,
but my goal moving forward now
is social entrepreneurship.
How can I bring more
business into the country?
How can I get people to want to
hire these rural communities?
And like I said, it's
not just a Haiti thing.
It's a Detroit thing.
It's a Compton thing.
The more we can work on
legislations and things
like that to help
pass, the less crime
that we'll have in these
different countries,
and the more we'll have
the Wyclef Jeans coming out
of these countries.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
WYCLEF JEAN: No problem.
MADELINE NELSON: Good question.
MATTHEW HENDERSHOT: Hey, Dama.
AUDIENCE: Hey, good afternoon.
WYCLEF JEAN: Good afternoon.
AUDIENCE: My name
is Dama, and I'm
one of the leads of the
Black Googlers network
here in New York.
So we just want to welcome
you and thank you for coming.
WYCLEF JEAN: Thank
you for having me.
It's It's very important.
We have a few Haitian
Googlers in the office.
Y'all raise your hands.
WYCLEF JEAN: Yeah.
[SPEAKING CREOLE]
Good, good, good, good.
AUDIENCE: And I think I also--
yes, actually-- I also want
to just amplify what you said.
WYCLEF JEAN: They said
"shalom," just so you know that.
AUDIENCE: I'm Puerto Rican.
It's not that far off, and I
understand Creole very well.
But I just want to
amplify what you said.
It's very easy to
critique people
who are going to their
countries to do work
for their countrymen.
I wish that here at Google,
we would focus as much
on what the American
Red Cross did in Haiti
and what we're not doing in
Flint as we are trying to focus
on what Wyclef did do in Haiti.
And I'll leave it at that.
Thank you so much for coming.
WYCLEF JEAN: Thank
you for having me.
[APPLAUSE]
AUDIENCE: Thanks for coming.
Not a question, just a thank
you for doing the open mic style
thing.
WYCLEF JEAN: You
already know, baby.
AUDIENCE: I'm not sure people
recognize how cool it is
and how hard it is to just
show up with a guitar and you.
And you gave us a behind the
scenes look at all these songs
that we love.
And a lot of people
don't do that.
So thanks.
WYCLEF JEAN: All right.
Thank you, buddy.
[APPLAUSE]
AUDIENCE: Hey, thank
you for being here.
I just had a question about how
you managed to get this far out
in your career and managed
to dodge so much shadiness
and snakiness in the industry.
Because we hear about it all
the time from the outside,
and it seems that you guys
got a good thing going
with independent
labels, companies
run by women and
stuff like that.
So how have you managed
to propel yourself
in the industry, that is
notoriously shaky, shady, stuff
like that.
Is
WYCLEF JEAN: Just raw honesty.
MADELINE NELSON: I want
to speak on that too.
WYCLEF JEAN: Just raw honesty.
What you see is what you get.
You know what I mean?
It's like, if you have a
question and I can't answer it,
we've got a problem.
And my father was a minister.
And he always said, "you
can't serve two masters."
So when I decided
that I was going
to do hip hop music,
he was like, "oh,
you worshipping the devil now.
You gotta get up
out of this church."
So he puts me upside
of this church.
And so now I become
a young little Fugee.
You feel me?
And I was like, "well,
what does he mean
you can't serve two masters?"
Maybe he was saying it wrong.
You know what I mean?
And I think the idea
of what he's saying
is, you're going inside of
industry, to your point, where
it's very, very turbulent.
And in order to stay
focused, it starts off
with the entourage
which is around you.
So a lot of us, we slip.
And I'm telling you, the rapper
is the best guy you'll meet.
But if you meet them
dudes from our hood?
And they're rolling with me?
Like, if I bought 20 of them?
Like, y'all be shook.
But the thing is, if
I'm going to bring them,
I have to be like, "look, dog.
We going to Google.
This is how we're
going to get down,
and everyone has to chill."
So what I've seen, what I've
seen through my entire career,
and it's a sad thing,
was the entourage
takes the rapper down.
The execs will do
anything they can
to keep the artists
on cocaine, on drugs,
or whatever to basically
get what they need out
of the artist and
basically spit him out.
And I'll let Madeline
continue on that, because she
has had a lot experiences.
Not that you spit me out.
MADELINE NELSON:
No, but to speak--
I wanted to really
speak to that as well.
Because our label
is women owned.
It's staffed only by women.
And the reason is because
I had an executive,
somebody I almost
worshipped, tell me
senior vice president at
Sony was maybe my pinnacle,
and maybe I would
get to be an EVP
and make a really great life
for myself, but as a woman,
I would never be CEO of a label.
And in that moment,
when the one Denzel tear
dropped from my left eye,
I don't remember which eye,
I knew I was going
to have an indie.
I was going to be
CEO of some label.
Maybe not a major.
But there is so much shadiness,
and not just toward women.
But the way you
navigate it literally
is to just navigate it.
One thing we knew with Wyclef
was that a "Carnival 3"
had to come.
If nothing else
happened, if he wasn't
going to do music anymore,
there had to be a "Carnival 3."
And so then how do you
then like look at him
like a brand that maybe had not
been embraced for a long time,
just the musical part of him?
And how do we brand it?
And so that's what we did,
the five women on our staff.
That's what we do.
That's what we figure out.
And literally how to just
learn how to navigate--
if you can't get
through a door, you do.
You go find the back
door, the side door,
and you go find the person
who will champion you.
And you just never--
to quote Diddy, "can't
stop, won't stop."
We literally walk around our
office saying those words,
"can't stop, won't stop."
You just find the door,
and you find the champions.
There's always a champion
for a certain kind of music,
a certain kind of
person, a certain kind
of what you believe in.
I was embracing what we could
do even on this platform,
on Google platform
and YouTube platform,
and having tons
of people tell me
I was crazy for spending so
much time trying to sort it out.
But here we are.
WYCLEF JEAN: Yeah.
Yeah, I'm going to tell
you, the toughest thing--
are you an artist?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
WYCLEF JEAN: OK, so
the toughest thing--
you seen that movie like Eddie
Kane, "The Five Heartbeats,"
you ever saw that movie?
AUDIENCE: Yeah, no.
WYCLEF JEAN: OK, you
should check it out.
Minus the drugs, that's like me.
Check it out.
Yo, I have absolutely--
I don't know how I ended
up being an artist,
because I just loved
the gift of music.
The first thing
with an artist is,
we're very sensitive to our art.
That's the first thing.
And I'm talking
about whether you're
a painter, an inventor, or
whatever, when you sit there,
you create.
I mean we got
fights, into fights.
I was like, "man, I'm
canceling this studio session.
I'm leaving."
But what happens is, if you
can get past the sensitivity,
because I'm telling
you, this sensitivity,
I've watched my
peers commit suicide
in the industry on
this sensitivity.
I've watched the
media take them down,
and they've read every
form of what they're saying
and started doing pills.
I think the first thing is, you
have to establish who you are.
So as artists, our job is to be
creative and bring creativity
to the world.
And for every negative
they say to you,
you have to take
it as a positive.
MADELINE NELSON: Yup.
WYCLEF JEAN: And that's
the hardest thing to do,
but this is what defines
success from failure.
So when a man says, I will
not rise, I go like Confucius.
You know what I mean?
Yo, the best thing is, after
I fall, I'm going to rise.
Easier said than done, but if
you can get to that pinnacle,
you are going to get to the
point that you need to go to.
But you have to believe
it in your heart.
AUDIENCE: Thank you, thank you.
MADELINE NELSON:
Find your tribe.
Find who's going to
champion what you do.
AUDIENCE: I'm building them now.
WYCLEF JEAN: He's part
of the Beard Tribe.
[LAUGHTER]
MATTHEW HENDERSHOT: I like that.
AUDIENCE: I'm going
to watch that movie.
MATTHEW HENDERSHOT:
Unfortunately, we've
run out of time.
WYCLEF JEAN: She has one.
MATTHEW HENDERSHOT: We can
take a couple, then rapid fire.
Just hit us with your questions,
and we'll try and address
them both.
AUDIENCE: How you doing, Wyclef?
WYCLEF JEAN: What up, baby?
AUDIENCE: Chilling, man.
MATTHEW HENDERSHOT:
We'll get back to you.
AUDIENCE: Being there you
come from an era of music
where there's so much content
and message behind your music,
how do you feel when
you have conversations
with your daughter and she's
into the Migos and things
like that?
Let's not get it twisted.
I like their music.
Like you say, cadence
is everything,
and it catches my attention.
But when I actually sit
down and listen to music,
it has no content.
Like, I could
quote you in a song
where you said, "in the
battle, I lost my finger.
The mic became my arm."
Feel me?
That has a lot of content,
a lot of meaning behind it.
And nowadays, a lot of
music doesn't have that.
What's your take on that?
WYCLEF JEAN: Well--
MATTHEW HENDERSHOT:
Before you take that,
let's get this question as well.
And then we can
address them both.
AUDIENCE: Similar
question, first of all,
thank you so much for the most
moving day within these walls
I've had here.
So thank you.
Question and a comment.
Question-- similar
to what you said,
what is the biggest thing
you've taught your daughter?
It sounds like your daughter
has taught you a lot about music
in the short time
she's been here.
WYCLEF JEAN: Yeah,
she's my manager.
AUDIENCE: And also--
MADELINE NELSON:
And his stylist.
AUDIENCE: Also a quick
comment/question.
If you can close out with a
song, that would be the dopest.
Just saying.
I'm just throwing it out there.
MATTHEW HENDERSHOT: I
leave that up to you.
WYCLEF JEAN: I'll do it.
Where's the mic.
MATTHEW HENDERSHOT:
Address the question first.
WYCLEF JEAN: I can,
and just take the mic,
and then sing, and then
we rock out and be done.
She's slick.
Boy, I told you, the women.
[LAUGHTER]
MATTHEW HENDERSHOT: You
want to come off with me?
MADELINE NELSON: Yeah, yeah.
WYCLEF JEAN: I got
you, I got you.
I knew I should have
taken my glasses off.
OK, yeah.
So what happens is,
to your question,
there's a lot of things
that are going on.
And one thing I want
you to understand
is, if you're looking
for lyrics and content
with young kids that are
doing what we're doing,
it does exist.
OK, let me tell you
where it exists.
So you're in a new era now.
You're in the era of streaming,
and everything is basically
on YouTube.
Are you aware of that battle
rapping around the world
is one of the number
one cultures starting
with Thailand?
And these kids are no older
than 20, 21 years old.
They're breaking metaphors
like the Fugees down.
They're doing this music
with absolutely no beats
behind them.
So what happens
is, we were talking
about the transformation
of cadence.
So there is a lot of
cadences going on.
Look at how many views
battle rap is getting.
Now, as far as what's
going on on the other side,
this is what's going on.
So my analogy in
watching my daughter,
she listens to music
purely for escape.
For entertainment
and for escape.
Now, when I look at her, I said,
man, the Twin Towers go down.
Every day, I mean you
go through the airport,
you practically have
to get butt naked.
The era that they're
living in right now,
everything is so fearful,
and everything is just
to scare them so
much that they got
two things they're going to do.
Either they're going to
start their revolution
and be like, "we protest.
We're going to
vote for a gorilla
before we vote for a person."
Or they're going to
escape with the music.
And I think that if we
can get our politics
right, our legislation right,
bring more love in the world,
kids will start to write more
about what they are feeling.
But right now, it's like
the kids are in escape mode.
We go to the party,
and it's like what do I
want to do, watch CNN
or listen to Migos?
I'll listen to Migos, because
I know exactly what CNN
is going to do.
But I think our job
though, my job, your job,
is when we put these
kind of albums out,
and then they're following
us, and we got their cadence.
And maybe through
the songs we'll
sing it'll inspire them to want
to do what we did back then.
You know what I mean?
So we'll try to do that.
[APPLAUSE]
What's your name?
AUDIENCE: Justine.
Justine.
WYCLEF JEAN: Justine?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
WYCLEF JEAN: OK.
[LAUGHTER]
(SINGING) Justine,
you know what I mean.
So sexy like a dream,
my Google girl.
[LAUGHTER]
[MUSIC - WYCLEF JEAN, "IF I WAS
PRESIDENT"]
[APPLAUSE]
MATTHEW HENDERSHOT: One
more time, Wyclef Jean.
Madeline Nelson, Heads Music.
[APPLAUSE]